hey joy to my right mr. Christopher
waters wait your turn hey way there's
Oreos furless first I am these guests
have to just wait to leave I'm it's
already gone bad should we start again
yeah don't worry about it take shape in
Amharic in my show this is your show
Danny what's on today's show dad to Tim
gets over here right there doesn't miss
me what are we gonna talk about your
army show today them coffee it really
crappy coffees in the third floor here
the coffee it's not official we branded
said Andrew it's it we're in cooperation
with them they're not actually
officially part of us don't I don't want
a drink this no but that's the
announcement for later we're gonna talk
we've got a big announcement later
that's them [ __ ] spill the beans this
early that's a good coffee right right
right right we shopped that earlier
today about games and broken age broken
age that's a game but that can came out
last year no no first half the first
half 2nd half of coming out today today
a right now if you're in north america
funeral it's tomorrow it's something
like that yet isn't it already tomorrow
in your I actually he's right that's all
I get it time travel it is already
tomorrow he's right that's Australia or
something no no no I guess it no Alden
ok confuse their like point five of our
demographic so we don't acknowledge
Australia I'm gangster we have an
Australian office which actually makes a
kind of awkward they acknowledge them
I'm sorry down under hey broken age yeah
act soon I'm good to get out of the
system all done it's like a real good I
was going to say a real good poop cuz
you get a decision that I don't want to
imply like that how does it feel to have
it out there you guys on the toilet for
three years yes if the game is better
than that it was better but it is as
satisfying I really the most successful
at toilets kickstarter in the history is
it actually still the most did well know
that it wasn't in time hey I think Brian
Brian's game made more afterwards ours
was the best yes yeah and they got a lot
of tension and then we made a
documentary you did not have you seen
that no documentaries up for free in our
YouTube him you guys create more
documentaries than we do is watch us
pretty much all the time yes it's like
there's more hours of us just sitting
there talking people at work watch it
and there was
change themselves in a meeting to have a
meeting and in the watch the episode of
themselves in a meeting in the room
they're watching the episode in but it's
still entertaining the impetus behind
all that stuff the two-player
productions right yeah it was was that
that was mostly born out of the sort of
extra goodies you wanted from the
Kickstarter right no it was the other
way around a they want to make a
documentary and they came down they said
because they had done a minecraft
documentary yes and they said do you
want to do documentary about a game
about like yes because I love attention
and then they say well we should
probably kick start a game to to go
along with it so we don't have to deal
with a publisher saying you can't put
the bad parts in right so we did a kick
start doing and so we were able to like
control the whole thing and show all the
bad parts and then some bad parts
happened and we should hmm but hopefully
people watching it enjoyed watching
ourselves is there like a bad parts
supercut that I can watch on youtube if
I just want to watch the bad parts you
can probably get a whole 20 minute was
the confirmation bias currently staring
at each other in a meeting like what are
we gonna do we just split it into two
yeah does that mean that all's well that
ends well yeah and what that what's it
like yeah what's it like top of that
they're in the world map one last one
it's fun it's out ticket it's out there
getting good reviews government to 90s
out their 60 s couple degenerate less
yeah i don't i should like i haven't
actually seen our review it's not it's
upside down so i wasn't really good but
you know luckily no credible scientist
haha and a lot of people when the first
one came out it's kind of like that
walking dead syndrome where which isn't
actually something to get a disease read
it by each and not quite at tore down my
ideas best called grassroots marketing
yeah they decided to kind of hold off on
playing the first one so they could
maybe no scared about that yeah spoiler
they could get any review would have the
spoiler it's really screenshot might
spoil the things yeah there's a pretty
total people like you play it now don't
wait and then when the director came has
like okay you should actually go back as
far as the beginning just to get all the
hints and stuff so that my
recommendations are really annoying do
you think people should walk play at all
as one as one because it wasn't you know
I'd really meant to be split in half so
there's got a lot of like hints and
stuff in the first half that pay off in
the second half remember really like
little hints in the dialogue and if we
made up previously on broken age it
would cause so much attention to
yeah like that I know how to solve this
puzzle now because of this previously
are there any like gags that you guys
have like set up a year early and then
hoping that the alignments like dumb
jokes that are set up in the first half
yeah it's true I what am I to do decide
to split it is easy too easy to play
with it if you know all the puzzles it
gets really when did you guys just
decide to spit it into the two because
it does kind of feel like an active one
an active not to give away the sort of
the real obvious aspect of white feels
like that but well any use during a
meeting where we're trafficker how we're
gonna whether we're going to cut the
game just cut it down and make it
shorter and I really didn't want to do
that and then actually her business guy
was like what if you ship the first half
to pay for the second half hmm and I was
against it for a while because people
have to wait to give this cliffhanger
yeah resolved but it turned out to be
good I mean turned out to help in that
we released it and we got a good
reception from it and we found out what
characters people liked or characters
you know or what puzzles they liked and
didn't like it were able to kind of
incorporate that into the second yeah
the second act was already going to be
like harder the first one just because
it's later in the game but we were able
to kind of feel like we had permission
to make it harder because the people who
play the first actress I hope it's
harder hopeful secure really even harder
oh yeah our anak my anecdotal evidence
of that is Mary Kish was playing it uh
early last week and I just see her
scribbling stuff down on paper noted and
getting vexed I was like I don't
remember having to write anything down
in the first half but I second i love it
when get the rights of slightly that map
you make it work when you're playing
Zork i was about to say in secret of
monkey island when I had to find the
bloody sword master the ladies you wrote
down the insults know the actually
abused later treasure map to get to the
to like other life right like yeah yeah
that one was a real like pen and paper
interest rates of town do you know that
you get was like too hard hard puzzles
not so much Lacey reviewers that was
kind of your like return to the the
genre you if not what created but sort
of made some of the most was around for
ya I made some of like the most beloved
games in I John What's it feel like
having a behind you now like that you
kind of dove back into this the result
for years people were talking about like
the death of adventure games if it's
like from a two decades what did it feel
like what's it feel like now to sort of
have gone back major you're the first
one in a long time and I haven't done it
was it was really eye-opening cuz it i
hadn't made him for for so many years
i'd forgotten a lot about what they're
like that they do a lot of work for like
ten minutes of gameplay so you can work
for three years and some will get
through it maybe 10 hours or something
like that and like so basically like it
you know they can finish it in men sale
what's next oh yeah all right let's make
another one you know so um but also
reminding the good parts of entry games
the things you like the the
opportunities for humor what you can
have in a lot of different games but
eventually aims allow certain pacing in
a certain depth of character that I
think you're really fun to craft craft
that's a craft as a verb oh yeah I'm
embarrassed you're a craft man this one
the master of your craft it didn't say
author you talked her yeah all those
yeah well then yeah yeah yeahs Elijah
Wood played the game he has played Act
one act two he been in 30 days kavitha
yet he has a code that should have I
just actually treated him now to tell
him I didn't play so hopefully obeyed is
he gonna do a review on Elijah Wood like
Oh what if he hates it oh god about
whatever like I did such a great
performance and these guys messed it up
in the editing room did you have to like
bring any of the voice actors back in
when you because presumably you'd
actually like yeah they recorded before
before we had to bring him back for a
second a second goes it pickups or was
at everything like did you have like a
lot of ACTU already there that you would
already require I mean if a jack black
we recorded his all his stuff in the
first half everyone else had an act one
session and Mac to session so some of
them by the time they did the accusation
had played the game or knew a lot more
about what we were doing and that was
really fun because they they got into it
to me neither Ferris the one character
we had a little girl who kind of aged
she was like two years older which is oh
you go from like you go
she saw his pics like this yeah exactly
she sounds like brenda vaccaro and high
that's a reference no one's gonna yeah
who's under 40 okay well that's for you
box what's he watching I don't know I
was talking about the Ravagers Oh
Chester oh yeah it's like all hey look
at you look in the rabbit ears Robert
looking the revenues you go liudmila are
you looking the rabbit Aviva oh it's not
like this one aries Robert ears Brian
hands aren't those are your hands
exchange the Robert ears haigo haigo do
anymore yeah what am I looking at the
revenues and aren't there they were
actually over there how many guys how
many games of you guys released this
unit 2 is I mean gone well again reactor
creamer masters uh broken age is
brothers house is bribe me were gonna is
that coming out yeah yeah he's all busy
with his baby the I saw he's having a
baby massive smash their phone or just
poor child the baby yeah it's gonna have
to grow into its mouth it's good it's
just like do you know about babies meds
like thing they're the same size their
whole lives you grow into the truth to
like baby Joker yeah okay no that's not
true yeah there's a picture of them last
week and everyone is freaking out about
it of the back lot of tattoos for an
infant to me sorry brah baby all right
we're not watching this over him poop
and barf right now well what are you
guys gonna work out a message house
he'll ship that and that'll be awesome
and secret thing Oh secret secret things
and we're not gonna tell people we're
working on anymore but we promised
everyone we have a secret things
unveiled was this wasn't my secret thing
we were hoping that maybe if we like
pressured you into it then you could you
know i'd like to make an announcement
but i don't have any oh that's a shame
day now damn do you know when it cuts to
you that you get a crouch behind your
face yeah oh yeah shoulder it's just a
crotch it's more it's the codpiece yeah
me and any clients is another word for
it sure can we cut to Chris can we get
me in my tank you're the only person to
share for this a bit like five minutes
getting the camera off there ya know
she's Umi right now for a fact but
really this is just my constant
companion here on the show it's
respectable thought bubble blue blue
blue blue purple he's thinking I really
buy a cod yeah as Brotherhood of Steel
am i right hehe you're the only person
that's ever noticed that you said it
multiple times oh I notice a constant
everything I mean if you
you are get pictures of yourself and
crotch is prominently featured intends
to other cultures around me whenever I
look at now we need more Mulroney hmm
it's not just how much predator mask
which actually makes no sense whatsoever
almost Hospital coffee all over tellin
that would have gone badly yeah / so
yeah any picture of me people are always
drawn to the crotch but for other
reasons so you guys kind of something
maybe free 3 or I don't have anything
for you three babies okay bees gangs
rising phoenix yeah yeah the PACU
clapped your game you can't say so is
that be great over there we're not an
audience we got today yeah that's the
famous sports but i see i see some
reflect I see reflective glasses back
there and only that I had the live
audience component here it's really who
would ever do a show with a live audio
yeah it doesn't seem smart yeah probably
peligro we just need a lot of positive
reinforcement I one updates about
Congress can they see they're doing
there's a new update and they hey what
are the updates about game bees Avengers
costumes that's for oh yeah we'll be
showing you my ps4 d great which is
awesome with move support have you
played it yeah please make it a gun be a
staple and violent that's and Thomas
best game ever are you guys gonna do the
sports friend things we're like two
people can share control or each get an
analog stick and then the buttons and
triggers on one side that is crazy yeah
what's crazy I took the bone low casa de
Bona we're just a helper here doesn't
help real tell them what to do we just
play the game we like it we're like um
how can we get a lot of free copy to
this game all we should help them
publish publish it then we can play it
all day lovely fellow any two player
production stuff a backbone off amazing
okay their what their base in the UK
right oh the basically k yes derivation
Sheffield Sheffield should I say the
name of the town there in oh yeah the
enemies have been looking for other
creditors oh there's no there they've
they be there upstanding fellows I'm
sure they wouldn't mind us saying there
enjoy let's give their address right now
everyone yeah so send your love letters
to actually although addresses in
England or something like like blue
house you leave his name's yes give like
a name of the house and everyone
supposed to just know where I had a
friend in a town over from me that was
the only time called this thing I'm just
gonna call it's a boat strand for the
sake of argument
Jenna he had like Patrick McCarthy boat
strand Ireland and male would get to
have this his name in the town yeah it's
we go Tim Schaefer thank you very much
coming up so fast congratulate they
mention broken age who did it's awesome
we talked about the bun I mentioned
crotches sure did we manage the stalking
you had your whole time without any
spoilers go play broken age should have
it is add on Steam oh it's a playstation
4 next PlayStation 4 and Vita and it's
on Android and iOS it's across by it's
on the ps4 and Vita is crossed by cross
save is a quad-core save as well Yeah
right on everything else that's crossed
save across even we use Dropbox oh you
like cross save between your everything
great and if you lose your save just
email tim above my walk you through it
tim schafer san francisco california
yeah we are doing a thing later I talked
about the thing later Gregor not sure
we're doing for doing actually like the
old lucasarts hit line you call we
bought of no but a phone we're gonna put
a number people get a call for hints is
it gonna cost like ten dollars a minute
you have it a sound system you just bail
in the cash later ok Tim I yeah inside
just go glam tower whatever in Ireland
concert Nina sure yeah alright that's
enough from clamtxt.com